more kills and caucuses viewer
discretion is advised
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
your Safari why the PM drive my name is
Patrick joining me behind the camera
today is Owen and we are coming to the
live from the juma Game Reserve here on
the western outskirts of the greater
Kruger National Park this drive is 100%
live and 100% interactive so if you do
have any questions or comments or
queries or anything along the way please
do send them in using the hashtag at
safari live on Twitter or the YouTube
chat stream so I'm sure a lot of at
least our regular viewers are very aware
of what happened last night / early this
morning with husana having his still his
kill was stolen by the inca homo pride
so there was a little bit of a hunt
which also involved a hyena and then
husana got the Impala took it up to a
tree waste of it and then inca home has
came and chased him out of the tree and
managed to take the kill for themselves
so what a very very hectic scene and
well one person who was part of that
scene was obviously asana and grant has
managed to catch up with him this
afternoon
good afternoon everybody and welcome
back to Jimmer this afternoon my name is
grant and I'm and drive with sins of
this afternoon and we have found husana
thanks to an earlier update from the dam
cam I believe he popped in for a drink
and headed off in the direction of the
wall and from there he didn't go very
far because he's just sort of found a
nice shady spot under the shade of some
timber tea trees now just after we
arrived he was completely flat out
having a nice afternoon nap and he
something picked up his attention and
there's two kudos that just wandered
into the scene obviously he he is
watching them but you never know I mean
you might be surprised could who's tend
to be slightly on the large side in
terms of pray for leopards no son is not
a little boy anymore so maybe if that
female kudu does something good
something a little bit silly then he
might ever have a chance but it is a
sort of towards the top end of the the
spectrum of sizes for lipids so the
problem at the moment obviously as you
can see between him and that could you
is a massive very open and very sunny
patch which you would struggle to cross
undetected so he's relying on his
brilliant camouflage at the moment and
judging by the Cudas behavior she may
have just seen some movement I think
he's also struggling to contain his
curiosity
but she's not sure so if the could who
had definitely seen him she would not
sort of glance away to casually she um
mrs. Anna that could be part of his plan
shame yeah he did have a bit of a rough
not having all of his hard work taken
away from him and could definitely be
looking for a replacement meal this is
quite ambitious like I said earlier but
you never know I've been surprised many
many times I'm watching these animals
interact but like I said now this stage
there is a bit of a gap between him and
her and she seems to be following the
male kudu who's headed off in the
direction that they came from it's if he
follows them you know some animals like
leopards predators in general don't
really want to put too much effort into
chasing or trying to catch something
that they know the chances are very slim
so let's just see what he does while she
walks off because he how he's lifting
his head up and his ears are pricked up
and he's listening quite carefully
yeah so the size of a kudu is generally
too large for leopards if you have to
sort of have a set of rules for them
things do happen that I mean I've seen
leopards with with young kudu kills
those females probably not fully grown
but she's just run off now but yes I
could is definitely towards the larger
end of the spectrum in terms of prey
species for for leopards if it was a
female leopard should have absolutely no
chance a female could he probably weighs
in the region of so 120 kilograms or so
and depending on her size and and her
age but it would be a little bit a
little bit big for a female leopard who
usually comes in and around 40 35 or 40
kilos so I'm asana I haven't weighed him
myself but he's a pretty chunky chap a
very big head strong neck um so if I had
to guess he'd probably be in the region
of sort of 65 or 70 kilos um
leopards have been known to lift
carcasses equal to their own body weight
up a tree which would mean that they're
lifting a big yarn and a stretch a shame
look at his empty belly doesn't look
like he had much to eat off of his meal
last night before the coup Houmas
arrived on scene look at that beautiful
coat
oh I think he's just gonna probably
settle into that little hollow there he
seems to like resting up in hollers and
and relax and let's just see what else
comes down here I might spend a bit of
time in the shade of these lovely timber
tea trees and you guys can head over to
Jamie who I believe is at the scene of a
crime on the bush walkers afternoon
we are at the scene of the crime so to
speak were actually at the scene of many
crimes a very good afternoon to you all
my name is Jamie and this afternoon
Sebastien is on a camera with me and
we're out on foot at one of hassanis
favorite haunts and I said it's the
scene of many crimes I actually suspect
that there have been more kills viewed
on the damn camera than there have been
viewed from our vehicles when it comes
to husana I was just imagining what it
must be like to be an Impala some nice
keen ish water over here there's some
water over there but when they coming
down from quarantine in the dark this is
the route that they have to walk and
they have to go around to this part of
the dam and from where I'm standing and
I stand a little bit taller where I was
standing I stand a little bit taller
than an Impala you can't see at all down
towards his favorite hidey hole which is
just below here down in this little
perfect little gully and it's basically
he spent so much time here that there's
almost husana sized
that's very pretty on a sized hole hmm
Egyptian goose baby just thinking aloud
suspected might be something like that
it's very pretty red when you look at it
this way we don't really because we see
the the Egyptian geese off and we don't
really stop to appreciate their colors
but this is actually very pretty indeed
so this husana sized hole is just
perfect for him it's clearly exactly
right and he feel safe and secure when
he lies down here probably all sorts of
ticks and things I'm gonna leave this
feather because
I don't know how many carries throughout
there is tasteless
it's arts whelk we're not the only ones
investigating the waterholes and there's
an Egyptian goose down here that I'm
just trying to get a good position so we
can have a look at its positioning is so
very awkwardly at the moment and kind of
running away from us whenever we get a
good shot but I'll describe what
happened in a second as soon as I get a
good spot here where have you gone I
have no idea where this thing is gone oh
there are these oh it's hiding in this
little just ah
so apparently Jamie just showed an
Egyptian goose a feather well there's
many feathers around here so we can see
it just in that little crevice down
there hiding away now I think what has
happened is that this african fish eagle
that we can see up in this dead tree
just over here when we first arrived on
the scene it was down in the water it
looks like it was going at something and
then well underneath it was this
Egyptian goose now it almost seems as if
the eagle was trying to hunt the grease
because the goose was completely
submerged in mud so much sorry that it
took us a couple of minutes to actually
see that it was there and submerged so
it's completely under the mud and there
is his feathers absolutely everywhere
here so there obviously was some form of
struggle now I don't know whether the
Egyptian goose it did actually heard
itself or somehow get itself submerged
in the mud or whether it was actual
attack from the african fish eagle
either way it was a very interesting
scene to show up on so if we have a look
at the outskirts of these live where I
put bubbles hook down by the way we have
a look at the outskirts we can see
there's a lot of feathers all around
from this struggle and Jamie said there
was a crime scene at the dam this
morning well there's also a crime scene
right here right now definitely not one
involving lines or leopards but still
the birds
how interesting yeah these are all
happening at the dams at the moment Emma
but this one now obviously quite shaken
up by the incident it was walking fine
it managed to get out of the water okay
no so everyone is asking whether there
is any visible injuries on the goose not
that I could see it's very covered in
mud it was almost completely covered
when it first came out is swam around a
bit which did kind of get it off the law
or here we go all right on cue so we can
see how muddy it still is all over the
head there so this body after swimming
got pretty cleaned off but it doesn't
seem to be any visible injuries and as
we can see moving around quite fine
obviously quite shake enough it would
looked very disorientated the way it was
swimming but carrying on carrying on
with a new head face of makeup yes I do
I do always get myself into a crime
scene oh so it's a no we say we'd like
to think that it's a lot of skill here
but sometimes it is just like just
showing up at the right place at the
right time and I seem to be doing that a
fair bit especially up in the Mara as
well I was very blessed with some of the
things that I just managed to come
across at the right time but actually no
I could have come across this no perhaps
a few minutes earlier and really I would
have been able to piece together exactly
what has happened but I mean given the
evidence we have that seems to be what
has occurred that there was a bit of an
attack from the fish eagle
I was just start to have seen a fish
eagle up so close
so I'm just gonna get this so he can see
Scuba Steve and snorkel Sam I believe
now that he has undergone his gender
change whole not change a change we just
figured that he was a male rather than a
female and we can really see that the
size similarity between the two it is a
bit hard to gauge when they are
submerged but we have one fully out
there if those of course being famous
for their blood sweat which is a
compound so that they secrete it acts as
a sin sunscreen and helps to protect
them from parasites and actually made
them part of the circus when back in the
day when that stuff was kind of not so
free under pond and someone else who
could be a part of the circus because
he's a little bit of a clown sometimes
is husana lets it go and catch back up
with him and grant
okay so still sitting with husana other
differently to the Egyptian goose that
everyone's just seen that's covered in
mud or saunas doing an incredibly good
job of keeping himself clean now we've
been watching him grooming for probably
the last five minutes or so and and he's
gone through his chest and his legs and
he just picked up the tip of his tail in
his mouth and he's just gently holding
it between his paws there and giving it
a proper wipe down that's one thing that
always amazes me immaculate ly clean
leopards always seem to be unlike myself
no matter how hard I try to wear a white
shirt and the bushes would be completely
messy but somehow that white on their
chest and on their belly is always
spotless walk absolutely not spotless
but very clean and white as is the Assam
I've spent any quality time with Hassan
and I can understand why everybody is so
fond of him now I haven't ever really
come across an ugly leopard but he is a
particularly handsome chap um I was
looking at photos of him earlier on and
his notice with male leopard often have
a what's referred to as a necklace of
spots around the around their neck on
their upper chest area and husana seems
to have two very distinct necklaces
which does make him look quite handsome
and those spots on his lower legs and on
his belly us big solid black
I mean contrast with that white which is
really really nice
so Rina I have had a pretty close look
at him with my binoculars to see if
there are any injuries on him from his
encounter last night obviously we didn't
catch up with him this morning so it's
been nice of him to be lying right out
in the open giving us an opportunity to
have a nice close look at him and he
looks to be in perfect condition um he
had one of his legs up earlier as he was
cleaning in the more difficult to reach
areas of his body and I had a look at
his paws and everything seems to be in
order
definitely no sign of any blood but that
would have been cleaned off whether it
was his or or from his meal last night
like I said a leopards are incredibly
good at cleaning but now when he when he
set up earlier and gave those kudos on
us close watch he moved and turned and
twisted exactly as a leopard should so
um you know they're pretty pretty smart
animals and those kinds of encounters
probably happen a lot more often than
even we know and we do get to see them
fairly regularly and so they they
generally get quite good at avoiding the
sharp ends of lions and hyenas and he
would usually climb right up into the
top of the tree to get away from the the
lions nasty nasty teeth and toes but I
think while we spend some time with
asana we're gonna send you back to Pat
to see what he's up to at the damn
well it's great to see Hassan still
hanging around and that he wasn't
injured or it didn't sustain anything at
too hectic during at last night's little
scuffle or this morning's little scuffle
but I would have thought I mean it
wouldn't surprise me if that did give
him a bit of a fright but lucky for us
he did come straight back the brave boy
now Here I am still with these hippos
and they're playing a lot nicer than
last time last time I was here with
these two one turned around and
proceeded to fling their dung in the
directly in the face of the other which
didn't look too pleasant asking and very
nicely it hasn't been too hot today
about 24 degrees Celsius about 75 76
degrees Fahrenheit that's still warm
enough for these two to be basking away
all day I remember when the first ever
Safari live hippopotamus related things
I ever saw was a video which I'm sure a
lot of you are all aware of James Hendry
trying to draw the hippopotamus and
absolutely losing at the plot it's still
one of my favorite Safari live moments
and it brings a tear to your eye to
watch absolutely hilarious it is an
absolute classic but I mean the point he
was trying to make is a good one in the
video that's all the sensory organs of
the hippopotamus itself are on the same
plane so when it is standing in the
water like we see it right now
all of the nose the mouth or eyes and
the ears are able to be above water and
functioning correctly and sensing what
they need to sense or smell or hearing
it looks like we have Impala out here to
my right about to come on down perhaps
for a drink before the missile out
cellto saying that he always finds
hippos so relaxing well so do i I love
spending time with them they do I mean
you wouldn't really guess from what you
see when you see hippo that they can get
so aggressive and so defensive but this
is something that we are wary of and
something we always need to keep an eye
on because as as bad as they can get
they can also want bad isn't the word
for it they're just doing what they do
defending their territory but as
aggressive as they can get I also threw
need to be handled like with respect and
always need to keep an eye on them so
here are those Impala looks like a
bachelor herd here
a bachelor heard being a group of males
generally the non-dominant ones as they
haven't been able to take over a home of
their own although rutting season is
pretty much closed down now we are
definitely definitely not hearing as
much sound from the impalas when I first
came here a couple of weeks ago there
was a lot of violence and gurgling when
I first came here it was quite quite
quite the scene quite a lot the scene
quite the audible scene perhaps that's
the right word for it
Cathleen where the hippos that go when
it all dries up well they will try and
relocate for water sources so although
they are completely dependent on water
they can move away from water for a
short period of time and so we use that
to try and relocate but they can also
utilize mud as well so you can also
observe hippos even in a slight puddle
or even just a super super muddy patch
but unfortunately if they can't do
either of that their skin will start to
crack up they will dehydrate and what's
going on is that I thought he was going
to do a complete barrel roll then cool
not sure what the purpose of that was
perhaps to give the other and lunch
tutino the Hebrews do not have a rutting
season like in parlor I'm not sure what
the season is here in Duma but in the
Mara it was like a lot of animals
actually in the Mara where there was no
real set breeding season but there was a
peak before the rains did come and I'm
assuming it would be a similar down here
in Duma especially because there is that
seasonal rain and we get so so much
water in sum or not so much water
compared to some reasons but definitely
a lot more than in the winter alrighty
well let's I'm gonna move on Nia move on
from these hippos and while I do that
let's send you to your Jaime on a bush
work he is contemplating a tree whatever
that means
it's actually one of my favorite spots
on Juma just because there's a huge game
trail that runs of between Galago pan
and the void Taylor dam where the camera
is and it's sort of dotted with these
huge jackal berry trees and the animals
love it here and I can see why there's
something so beautiful about these
jackal berry trees with a thick dark
foliage and their dark bark is also
quite a substantial termite mound I
didn't realize until I started climbing
at just how steep it actually was but
the thing about jackal berry trees is
that they're easy to climb not just for
leopards but for lions as well everyone
always talks about the fact that
leopards are such good climbers look
Lions can climb and we've seen it in the
Mara most of you have seen it in the
Mara and they often steal leopard kills
from them I suspect that this happens
more often than we know it's only just
because the damn camera happened to be
there that we knew that that scene
unfolded at all we could have read it
from the tracks probably well there was
such a confusion this morning that I'm
not even necessarily sure that we could
have I could go Rollie pollie down this
hill actually pull of Scuba Steve mmm I
think that husana probably encounters
lines possibly weekly possibly even more
frequently depending upon where he is
but I think that it's something that
he's pretty familiar with if not
comfortable with probably comfortable
would not be the right turn of phrase
but he he's going to choose a jackal
Barry he runs the risk of a lion
climbing up it
I sometimes wonder you know if that's
not why do we often find a pit kills in
peltor forums which are the weeping
wattles because they're almost always a
little bit too uncomfortable for the
Lions to climb although then they can
just climb up and grab it anyway just
pull the tree over that is I do think it
is something that happens quite
regularly but moving on to the Lions
because we've seen husana he's okay I
think he's learned a few things since
his encounter with the Avoca male herbie
was out all day today or should we have
to say a very big thank you tracking the
Lions
you could only find where one lioness
went and then one Linus went towards
Sydney's dam now we don't know for
certain but wait no let's rephrase that
we do know for certain that one of the
implements has Cubs because Ali has sent
us a message to say look there are kiyow
kiyow suckle marks not believe that some
of you could see them on the dam cam
last night so one of the females has
Cubs Trista and I were having a
conversation in the car on the way home
today about whether or not those Cubs
could be on Juma or not and where they
might be you know typically when a
lioness has got cubs she's going to the
same place backwards forwards backwards
forwards backwards forwards twice a day
every day sometimes three times a day
and we haven't noticed that we haven't
seen the tracks but as Justin said we
might have missed it with a number of
male tracks wandering around I see you
Herbie yes
he's just whistling at each other you
know Jamie it's an old whistle that we
used to whistle at each other right so
where are the in Kakuma Cubs where is
the one place that the Inca homers have
been moving constantly and now that I
think about it the answer is just behind
Sydney's dam in Buffalo up Manny Leyte
on that boundary that's where they've
been going crossing in out of Simba
Billy all their own little Gary or or
they're on Juma and we've missed
something which is possibility might be
why the Evoque has have been with us the
entire time right so while we
concentrate on finding Herbie who
himself is desperate to find where the
other two lionesses went grant beat us
to our mission this afternoon and found
her sana for us
yes very relaxed indeed Jaime he has
obviously gotten over his most recent
lion encounter and is sleeping it off
nicely in the shade you for a cool
breeze that just rolled in and some
bloody trees still providing him a nice
spot to rest for now he's finished his
birthing routine feeling like he's clean
enough and he's found a lot so soft
pillow just on the edge of that dried-up
my doll are they he's just tucked in
there ever so neatly as we drove in here
as well I was just saying to sins of it
if he were lying on these dried fallen
leaves of the tomboy tea trees he might
be very difficult to see as I ended that
sentence we saw him lying slightly sort
of more towards us from where he is now
but right in the middle of a nice open
sandy patch so he wasn't too difficult
to spot but and I don't even want to
know how many tons of driven right past
a sleeping leopard in a last patch of
grass and had absolutely no idea about
it let alone the amount of times he's
sort of you spend walking and tracking
to try and find them and surprise you by
jumping out of the grass not too far in
front of you and what levers tend to do
a lot of the time is very much rely are
they very confident of their a
camouflage and they expect that you'll
just walk right past him which also
happens and sometimes if you do get a
little bit too close and haven't seen
them then they'll just jump up and move
off
but yeah he's nice and hot and I've been
there for us to have a good look at him
let's have a bit of a closer look just
grab my binoculars
absolutely Peter you and myself and I'm
sure many other people are very happy
that Sanne got away unscathed you do go
very attached to these individual
animals being up in areas like the sabi
sands we get very much a part of their
lives and become quite involved in the
sort of day-to-day encounters and what's
gonna happen and what has just happened
so yeah that very glad he's okay and we
can continue to enjoy his presence in
the meantime while we enjoy watching
this beautiful sleeping cat I'll send
you back to Pat who's spending some
quality time with some hippos well we
have a little bit of mayo displays here
in both both senses of the word with I
mean sorry with both species so we have
these Impala here who were doing a
little bit of Jason here we go we've got
some going on there and whilst that is
going on there is also hippo spraying
his poo in the foreground which is well
they're both displays of dominance in
males or fighting in the Impala and it's
also at something hippopotamus will do
to mark their territory or I'll show you
their dominance over another male is
they'll position themselves kind of head
to bum and spray their poop but it
doesn't look like anything serious in
these impala obviously as I said it is a
bachelor herd and not a not a harem
there's no females here so it's not a
serious fight for females and well now
that's especially now that rutting
season is finished I think it's just a
little bit of a not so much a play fight
you know just figuring out the dominance
hierarchy although it has definitely
settled it down at the moment it still
is a thing and it is something that is
occurring so anyway my original plans I
never actually told you about my plans
this afternoon I was looking at for the
Inka homers but I have heard they have
crossed north over to your Bulls hook so
I did just come through look the
property that is north of where we are
right now where we are is that book this
hook dam which is actually off the
property but I think I might still head
it down to where they last seen and just
have a little bit of a poke around and
see what I can come up with
looks like these Impala we're going to
come drink but it doesn't look like that
anymore so off we go
is that Egyptian goose still looking
very muddy I'll just stop here so we can
have another look no Emma I won't go
driving us in the book
I've been marshmallow one too many times
during my time here are those never
happened in Toomer and I hope it never
does happen oh we can still be safe this
this Egyptian goose which is neither a
goose nor a duck they are classed in
shell duck and yes this goose also got
marshmallow that's a very good point
ever Emma
very good point marshmallow worse than
me it got this whole body stuck in the
mud at least in me it was only my lower
half alright continuing on providing it
this grease does get out of the road
I hope you recover the fish Eagles still
up in the tree
perhaps that's what's made it so nervous
and coming away from the dam
so the goose will start to preen itself
and as it goes more and more into the
water it will probably start to wash a
lot of that mud off so although it is a
muddy like that for now it won't be like
that before good but as for its face I'm
not sure how it's going to go about that
I'm sure it'll just eventually come off
with the water and perhaps a little bit
of rubbing and cleaning I'm really
hoping I can at least get a visual on
the Inka whom is this afternoon because
as everyone is very curious about the
Cubs and how many are lactating and well
that duck was quite dirty but one boy
who keeps himself very clean is our star
horse Anna let it go yet back over to
him very clean indeed yeah it would be
interesting to try and see where the
Inka homers have wandered off to they
definitely did give us the runaround
this morning we had tracks going in all
different directions last night and it
would be nice to know what they've done
with themselves and so far no sign of
Tandy this afternoon there was some
alarm calling Franklin's just north of
camp earlier on this afternoon and so
maybe she's hanging around towards
Gallagher Pen maybe in those drainage
lands somewhere we were hoping that she
might pop in and pay hassanover xored
and always nice to see some encounters
especially been between different
individuals of lipids but for the
meantime he's been pretty undisturbed
since the kiddos left
we were visited by a yellow-billed
hornball and that's pretty much it would
a lipid drop its killed to escape from
lions mean I mean I I don't think they
would intentionally do that um you know
what if a leopard was trying to escape
from Lions in a tree and the kill was in
the tree in certain situations like last
night they can climb some of the larger
trees with heavier branches in that
scenario I think the leopards plan would
probably be to just both try and stay
away from the Lions and I'm at the same
time try and keep his kill
I don't think intentionally giving it
away although that would give them a
good distraction
I think the first plan on his on his
mind is to try and get further away from
the lines which you'd usually be right
up into the thin branches of the trees I
mean you'd be amazed the the size of the
small branches that a leopard needs to
sit in and I was just looking up at this
knob thorn behind hasanah
now I don't know if you could have a
guess roughly how high you would get
into that tree my guess would be sort of
up into that top left corner of bunch of
branches in the top left of the screen
there that's it I have seen lepers right
up into thin branches like that before
they're incredibly good at at
negotiating breaking branches and things
as well but there would be no chance of
a lion getting that high up into a tree
when you do sit and watch leopards that
have oyster to kill you'll often find
hyenas and things gathering around the
bottom of the tree and I've been for
scraps to fall down I think it is quite
a nice sort of system for the hyenas to
benefit from something like that but
I definitely don't think it's
intentional because if you have to watch
the the lipids sort of facial expression
as the bits and pieces of his harder and
kill are falling to the hyenas he's kind
of disappointed for a few seconds the
bits and pieces that usually fall out of
the trees are like the thin bits of bone
with is there's no meat or any sort of
nutritional value to them that they
usually drop down and of course the
hyenas just crunch all of that up and
eat it snapping away every now and then
you'll Flickr's ear to chase some flies
away it's a nice thing about this winter
this winter weather yeah bones delicious
I'm not sure maybe if you're a hyena
they don't seem to be too picky so I
think bones and things like that would
be delicious for them but yeah I was
just gonna say that the last thing about
these wintry afternoons is the warm Sun
and the cool breeze you never really get
too hot especially with a nice spot like
horse owners in seeing flickers you can
actually see the flies that are buzzing
around him there I don't know if anyone
else has ever been in the position of
trying to nap while a bunch of flies are
busy interrupting you every few seconds
but leopards seem to have that down to a
fine light but while we continue to
search with husana we'll see if he does
anything more than sleep off his
afternoon bull send you back to Jamey on
her bush walk solutely correct in that
this time of year the temperature is so
pleasant and for those of us who now are
we walking almost in fact we're walking
pretty much every afternoon it is even
more pleasant because you don't feel the
cold right up until the point that you
finish your walk
and instead of the sort of blistering 40
degree heat it's actually really quite
lovely
to walk at this time of year thus at the
same time if you need to you can cover
ground more quickly because you can see
into the vegetation not too quickly when
the cameraman swimming because otherwise
they fall over and get cross and we
don't walk too fast
despite Herbie's desperately desperately
to find these other two lionesses
something that we all share all have in
common
what's happened what we figured because
we've gone and we've checked all the way
in a loop around to the north we figured
that they must have gone south and that
the one-niners must have split most
likely the one with Cubs because that
just makes sense we no one's got suckle
marks the other two have gone back south
towards the pride we think they've gone
back south towards the pride that's what
we're hoping anyway so that's going to
assist us in the search for the Inca
Houmas if he finds any tracks we'll call
him in we've been to check the old hyena
den on a verbal road for those of you
that remember the old hyena den there it
was a mansion the beautiful beautiful
den and eventually if I remember
correctly and my memory could be faulty
here but I don't think it is if I
remember correctly the hyenas eventually
moved out of Jummah as the result of the
fact that the unco Houmas were Denning
so close to their den it was the old
lioness who had her den here the middle
state of Cubs she gained them in the
side hmm
so mean calm has come back and in on
Juma oh but I want to see a lion cub
when last I see a lion cub a little
little lion cub I think the last time I
saw a small kerb under the age of a
couple of months was in the Mara
I can't remember some time in the Mara I
saw the all our laws when they were very
little I mean yes they were lawless I
couldn't remember what they were called
for a second and the marsh breakaways
and they're so cute
that's not of course to say that they're
not still lovely as they grow up as
we've had to learn with hisana
as he's got older our love just changes
and crows very adorable indeed Jaime and
he has just got up and down a little bit
of moving look at that shade that
dappled shade on his coat there really
stands out huh how well his camouflage
works you might just go and have a look
around
see if anything is coming down towards
the water or just change his position
look at that's dawn so the muscles and
the back of his neck and his shoulders
that long tail it's always good to pay
attention to that tail of theirs it can
be quite descriptive of their sort of
their attention if you can put it that
way if they do see something interesting
that tail is incredibly dexterous look
at that you see that little wag that he
did there it's either just saying uh
maybe there's nothing here when that
tail starts jiggling from side to side
he's usually they have picked up on
something interesting we've just lost
him he looks like he's coming back to
the left here we might have to do a
little bit of maneuvering here
is to see if we can keep up with him is
better to go around this right here
lawanna that's a nice question actually
end with the lipids don't sleep on the
ground because it's too dangerous for
them now it definitely does put them in
the position that something might sneak
up on them they do sometimes fall into a
deeper sleep way where you you might
sort of be able to get a little bit too
close to them without them realizing
otherwise they usually pick up on on
sounds that would indicate movement in
the area and what you might notice is
that they usually won't go and sleep
right out in the middle of a massive
open area but rather somewhere close to
a a big tree very a little bit bumpy
somewhere close to a big tree well they
could quickly - up if a lion or a hyena
had to surprise them but saying that
sleeping in trees is done from time to
time as long as I can find a nice wide
enough branch - to spread out on it
would usually be more comfortable lying
on the ground for them so you do more
often find them sleeping on the ground
but within reach of the safety of a nice
big tree
now let's just see there's quite a lot
of little winding drainage lines here
which you see is perfect leopard habitat
now we were just parked over there
earlier and he slipped over to the
left-hand side of this Ridge so let's
see if Wendy can squeeze us through here
the wonderful little vehicles I'm sure
she'll have no problem doing that
he is very sneaky as on my snippet the
ease with which they disappear is never
I mean it's always surprising okay so
and while I do a bit of negotiating here
we just watch your heads um I'm gonna
send you back to to Pat who is busy
tracking me
hopefully you can get through it I was
put through the exact same in situation
that last night then well it can be
quite the tricky one to negotiate so as
I said the infamous were seen up sort of
moving Northwest and they have been seen
over in Buffalo but I'm just gonna come
down that direction anyway there are
fresh tracks going that way but I
believe they would have been from
earlier when they were seen moving at
this direction but you just never know
they may have crossed back over you know
anything something that's got their
attention or perhaps just coming back
for some water there could be a number
of reasons for them to cross back over
and it's something we do see in cats
sometimes you'll be following a set of
tracks one direction and then you'll
find some going at the complete other
side but definitely tracks all over the
road four lines I haven't seen any small
ones though no signs of any Cubs but
definitely some bigger lines in the mix
and it looks like a couple of lioness as
well
so poor poor husana finally gets himself
an Impala and has it stolen right
literally right from underneath his nose
and well hopefully tonight he can have
another go and get something and
hopefully if those loins are away
well it seems that way everyone is
wondering whether the Inca homers have a
split up now I obviously myself haven't
seen them but it does seem that way from
what I've heard and what these trucks
are doing as well each set of tracks of
lines I've come across have quite have
only been through two three lines each
and they were kind of haphazardly along
this road which also tells me that they
may have been split up a little bit well
especially if they do have Cubs and the
Cubs may still be at the den site
somewhere that's another reason that
they could be split up so well so I
don't know exactly for sure it does seem
to be that way that was something we
would see quite a lot up in the Mara
with the bigger prides of lions such as
the ole Ola laws and the river pride is
that that looks like snakes been across
the road there sorry there's just some
tracks for a snake crossing the road I
just had a quick look but snakes can be
quite elusive down here figure prides
they were always split up and even
prides like the old way knows especially
when button up had her cubs we would
always see them split up and well I try
and find these Lions I'll send you back
over to Jamie who also loves to
reminisce about the aula laurels in the
oh he knows
I have been reminiscing about the all
along laws that know he knows I mean I
remember when all of those listening to
it would pick it at the same time and I
remember when the all alors had their
first set of Cubs during our first few
weeks in the Maasai Mara it was
absolutely stunning tiny little bundles
in the drain at that really steep lager
in Kenya big river system that drained
down from the marsh your wee nose I
remember a little pale lioness so yes
there's lots to reminisce about some
happy some sad but life carries on and
I'm hoping that when you know in the
light of the oldest lionesses death from
the Inca human pride I'm hoping that
some new little cub sightings might give
us a little bit of renewed joy I guess
we've got a big circle all the way
around the backside of the dam or not
the backside the north western side of
the dam and now we're heading round to
the east and to the south a bright night
wants to know if amber eyes has Cubs she
if I'm not mistaken it is the originals
lioness that looks as though she's got
suckle marks from what Ali said and it
looks as though the one-eyed lioness and
another lioness have got one eye but the
purple eyed lioness has have are
lactating or at least have milk pouches
of look oh there's Patrick about to walk
into him no it's not with anyone walking
to grant I think mm-hmm what was I
saying
oh I don't know if it was amber eyes I
we're not sure yet we'll try and get
some clarity obviously as soon as we see
them amber has not had much success when
it comes to raising cubs I think that
we've actually countered five failed
attempts that we know of to and almost
always the Cubs have not made it quite
past their first few months of life
shame those last little ones I didn't
even get to see
actually none of them I got to see come
to think of it so we really really are
all rooting for and buyers just hasn't
worked out in our favor hopefully this
time you can synchronize in with the
rest of a pride have a Cubs at the same
time as the other lionesses then of
course she's got the allo suckling
potential of that a fairly substantial
pride now when you think about it
the force about also reaching maturity
some have reached maturity so that's for
a lot lionesses plus the now for
original adults so a lot of ello
suckling potential hope he's got us so
well trained Suzie stops don't step on
the tractor and step on the track and
we've looped all the way around and back
down here I hope amber has Cubs and I
hope they're successful right I just saw
a grant drive past I assume that means
that we're not about to walk straight
into a husana judging by the speed he
was driving at let's go and find out
whether or not he has any ideas as to
where Hassan has gone and if you'd like
some help
quite possibly Jamie I did see you
coming down in this direction but he is
walking away from them fortunately but
we haven't located him yet but we just
coming down back into the drainage line
hopefully just a little bit further
ahead and in the direction that he was
walking in okay so that's cool since I
said you just saw some impalas I do see
them as well just up ahead there um I
just want to update the other vehicles
that they don't chase him or gonna
interfere with hasana trying to get
another meal but stations yeah
some impalas is further up ahead along
the drainage line from way son is okay
and it's just okay seems like he may
have seen them running across the
drainage I wonder if I should just we
just stop here for a second and I just
see you can see the impalas they're off
to our left just glancing up in the
direction of where hosanna is coming
from if he has seen them he would
definitely have taken cover now one
thing he has to his advantage in the
direction that he's coming from is that
the Sun is behind him so even as I try
and look in this direction to see if we
can see anything sun is shining straight
in my eyes so that would be an advantage
for him over the position of the impalas
at the moment and I think we're in a
pretty good position at the moment to
just sit and see what happens that we
can usually judge from the impalas
reactions as well just what might be
happening with with the leopard if they
do see him then we might hear an alarm
call but otherwise you can see them
paying attention up towards his
direction so it's a good chance that
he's still up there as well so everybody
is switched off now and we'll just spend
a little bit of time sitting listening
since us checking the wind here which is
also an important thing and I think it
is in his favour as well which means
it's blowing from the impalas towards
where Hosanna is you can see that as a
young male Impala they're probably in
the region of two years old would be the
ideal size ideal size late lunch for him
so Daniel I just heard the beginning of
your question about hunting an Impala it
is and like I said an ideal size and I'm
all for horse honor to to UM to hunt mr.
dennell very handsome Impaler indeed and
they're also very sleek and good-looking
animals I don't know if that contributes
to the leopards preference of them um
but they do tend to enjoy the Impala
probably more because of their size now
he's just gone back down into the
drainage which is more ideal for for
sauna in this situation it's unless that
Impala is just dashed at the other side
of the drainage line now I'll just give
it a few seconds and then we'll age
forward just along this track a little
bit and just see if we can see what
those impalas have done I haven't heard
any sound so they definitely haven't
seen him otherwise we would have heard a
classic snorting alarm call sort of a
sound that's made out of their nostrils
which they haven't done so
can you see anything from up there since
I was I think maybe let's just let's
just edged forward down this track a
little bit and see see if we can see
anything
um impalas the long haul
is very unique in terms of the
difference between the other calls that
they make and so the only other sounds
that you'll hear from impalas which is
usually three I'm not mistaken I pretty
much I think of only heard three the one
is the alarm coach is a snorting
snorting sort of nasal sound like that
sort of sound then the sound of a
rutting male Impala which is more of
like a boo look more sort of rude sir
hunting sound as they chase and and urge
the females let's just see if they've
seen where he's moved to okay I think
yeah just looking at what everyone on
the other vehicles looking I think he's
somewhere right in front of us I'm just
gonna move a little bit forward here and
we might be able to see him walk down
past us through the drainage line there
we go okay great
there yes sir he is still looking
straight towards those impalas which he
did see turning by his behavior and they
I can see them as well still actually
don't know if if you'll get him there
since oh it might be a little bit too
high for you through the leaves but he
yeah he's actually in a great position
you have ELISA see what happens he's
probably if I had to guess he's probably
about
50 meters off from the impalas which
which is a pretty good pretty good
distance and unlike the sighting earlier
with the kudu and and husana there the
distance between him is covered with
tumbler tea trees in shade the wind is
in his favour and the Sun is behind him
so let's hope our boy gets to replace
his mule from last night quite happy
with our position as well here because
we are off to the side so we're not
parked behind him which wouldn't draw
any attention in the direction in the
direction of where he's sitting and he
is just watching very intently
absolutely Daniel this is the perfect
kind of cover if you want to put it that
way for for a leopard to blend and look
at that golden color of his coat the
golden color of the Sun and the
reddish-brown color of the leaves at the
moment it is absolutely perfect they
almost become invisible in this kind of
environment
you can see how he's just sitting very
still and listening I think what he's
thinking about at the moment is how many
impalas are yeah I've seen I can see
from where I'm sitting I can see - they
both seem to be young males Oh 3 is 3
and they're all 2 year old male Impala
at least 3 they might be more obviously
the more impalas they are it's the more
difficult it becomes for him to sneak up
to them undetected more sets of eyes
more sets of ears to pick up on his
movements
wonder what he would do you know I'm
just trying to think it's quite
difficult usually to think like a
leopard but stay undetected is his
number one priority but in terms of his
approach if he moves a little bit
towards us he's gonna be in the Sun
which he wouldn't do because it would
cost a shadow in the direction of the
impalas but while I'm trying to still
figure out how a leopard thinks I'll
send you back to Jamie who is doing
something with giraffes I'm not sure but
let's go and have a look well I've
suppose it was quite tall especially
with the antenna I mean uh I'm a lot of
things but tall he's definitely not one
of them
I'm very accepting of the size that I am
skinny maybe perhaps might be a good
description and of course with two left
feet so yes actually I get it I get
where he was going now if it didn't
before I've made it work right we did
find something really beautiful one of
those funny little jewels of the bush
that you know so often is missed when
you're driving along that's why being
out on walk is so special this
particular egg probably belonged to an
era marked babbler if not an era marked
babbler perhaps a Starling and obviously
what's immediately striking is that blue
color I'm trying to think of what I'm
think of a better word than blue I mean
I'm a girl I should know different names
for colors best suggestion for the color
of this egg hashtag Safari live on
Twitter or in you know comments section
of the you poor YouTube chat Emma says
turquoise or aqua I would have gone with
cyan mm-hmm sorry - okay sips is
turquoise can I tell you what else it is
really smelly really stinky and for some
reason I said to save as I picked it up
hit a mrs. duck egg blue mmm some reason
I says to say if it's really disgusting
so I picked it up and smelt it
put it right up to his nose no he didn't
vomit he's still good I mean it's a
rotten egg that's what it stinks of
because there's although remaining
albumin from where the chick you know
the albumin of course is for the chicks
food supply no you can't say that ever
it stinks I could smell it from here
it is really really stinky and I think
I've got the cold that's been going on
the camp oh I like that Sharon says sea
foam that's very pretty
okay let's expand this doesn't have to
be one word it can be an expression whoo
tabby says tiffany blue hmm the same
blue as the sky on a winter's morning no
you know what this the blue of a sky of
the sky on a winter's morning in a
European country because our sky doesn't
go that color B not really not often but
in an in a European country I think that
could work winter sky pale pale the
color of somebody very cute I says Emma
okay well we know what Emma's type is or
at least what I color they go with that
she would go for a my own two eyes this
color no famous eyes are brown oh yeah
yours are Brown sorry mzo Brown I said I
think your eyes are nice and Chris's
greenish blue yes okay fair save saying
the color of Casey's eyes which is very
sweet that's his daughter for those of
you that don't know she's 6 mm-hmm she's
6 years old which is really sweet but
much less smelly or at least Casey's
much less smelly
could have gone both ways I know it
wasn't even listening as I said that to
who I'm sending you across to sir can be
a surprise for you
for me and possibly for Seb on the move
indeed but very very very gently
I feel Lucky's he has literally gone as
flat as a rug and sneaking
towards the impalas another reason he's
done that it's because as this Impala
was feeding it moved slightly towards
him and behind a clump of grass and
fallen branches which offered him the
cover necessary to move so there's four
impalas there now they're handling a
little bit away from him
let's just see it all just aging aging--
the accuracy of his movements is
phenomenal
he watches very carefully each Impala
simultaneously and make sure that none
of them are looking in his direction and
then he makes a move if you can see
there it's very difficult to see him in
that grass but the distance between them
and between the impalas and the leopard
there's a little bit more apparent there
if I had to give you a guess he's
probably about 10 to 12 meters off
and the good thing is that these impalas
are actually quite busy feeding and
moving about so they're quite occupied
in themselves and what they're doing at
the moment and they're they're in a very
precarious type of habitat to be
behaving so casually and asana was in
the right place Oh
he is just absolutely frozen because one
of the impalas just lifted its head up
[Laughter]
unis that is a great comment crouching
leopard chewing impala that's exactly
what we were watching here no hidden
dragon but the intensity of the scenario
definitely Trump's all others at the
moment that Impala very nearly caught
Timothy and even at this point it's
still very much
touch-and-go he would miss watching
those impalas he would very much
appreciate one of those impalas to move
towards him which would be the most
ideal in this situation
let's see they haven't actually chosen
any particular direction like I said
they're just winding in and out of all
those bushes is he feeding on my I think
they're eating Tom but is there no some
spikes on some small Tam booties he is
absolutely silent up there is at least
audible to us there is absolutely no
sound of his movement and if you compare
that to the gentle sounds even of the
very delicate hooves of the impalas you
can hear them quite clearly on the dry
leaves as they're moving in and out of
the thicket but somehow he manages to
either place his feet just in between
the patches of dry leaves as he moves or
the very soft and furry nature of the
bottom of his pads they're very furry
between the toes does helped him muffle
his footfalls as well oh sorry I'm
trying to control my excitement here as
well but the situation with these
impalas like I mentioned they're all
males which kind of helps in the way
that they'll sometimes jostle between
it's very difficult to control your
excitement when it gets this close um
but yes the males between themselves
will sometimes push and shove and jostle
and every now and then one of them sort
of jumps in the direction of husana
which
could change things for husana for the
better for the impala unfortunately not
so good but we all know that that is
part of life idea so I think he's also
store recovering from his last move
where he very nearly got caught out and
he has stayed in the exact same position
impalas are most likely in towards the
back now so he's just lifting his nose
to try and keep a good view of them
let's just see what happens yeah give it
a few more seconds these things can take
five minutes they can take an hour so
we'll have to just wait and see what
transpires it's something as simple as
one of those impalas jumping off in his
direction could could change things
it's watching those impalas on nibbling
I was gonna mention earlier about their
diet and the fact that they might be
nibbling on some tambuti leaves it
embodies a fairly toxic tree as well and
it's not dangerous for the impalas but
what have an impact on their awareness
some viewers are wondering if there's
any baby impalas around not at this time
of the year the rutting season is pretty
much just ended as Pat mentioned earlier
so most of the adult females will be
pregnant from now going forwards towards
November December when they will usually
give birth at roughly the same time as
one another and then there will be lots
of babies around
these ones are babies from two years ago
so they're not complete adult yet but
you can see their horns are sort of
diamond-shaped
where they're where the points are
pointing in towards each other and that
will put them at roughly two years old
for a male Impala
but it seems to be just a small bachelor
group of males
Gaeta don't think that all sauna has too
much to be unconfident about at this
stage he is quite a big male already
he's not fully grown but in the region
of around about three years he should
have a pretty good idea of the
techniques involved with hunting and
just sitting here watching his behavior
he's doing everything by the book
and so at this stage I would say his
confidence is pretty good last night he
did manage to get something
unfortunately the Lions got the better
of him but yeah this is his confidence
didn't have much to do with that so he's
just moving there again but yeah the the
the length of time that this takes very
much depends on the situation the wind
the especially the movement and behavior
of the Impala so he it's actually
showing more confidence and more
experience that he hasn't just rushed in
and given it a try which sometimes young
younger lipids would tend to do they get
too overeager and sometimes put a foot
wrong and then it gives him away
completely to the impalas of just now
turned and faced at an angle away from
him so he is trying ever so carefully to
sneak forward it's almost like a snake
is big belly is so low to the ground
there
ah I'm shaking in my seat with the
anticipation it never I don't know you
never kind of get over it it's if you do
then I think the bush is not a place for
you to spend too much time because this
level of intensity gets my palms are
sweaty and my voice a little bit jittery
and I'm sure most of you have heard the
term leopard crawl and maybe you've even
tried to impersonate it but if you watch
if you watch a leopard do it it is such
a good example of what that term
actually means the one of this kill is
important for his survival although it
wouldn't make or break it he would
absolutely love a meal now of course
especially after last night's
transporation z-- he would definitely
appreciate it but they can go for quite
an extended period of time without a
meal although they might be
uncomfortable and it would take hard to
guess but I mean it would take a few
weeks at least for that to start wearing
down their strength and ability to to
hunt and look for a meal but he is still
in very good condition although his
belly is a little bit empty
completely flat I think his chin might
even be on the ground he's lifted it a
little bit the impalas usually as the
Sun starts setting will start moving out
into more open areas to sleep or to rest
at least during the evening the night
time because they know that animals like
asana look at that you can almost see
his excitement as his legs sort of
twitch
to try and find a quiet spot to put his
paw down
the yoga pose ah there they go they've
seen him my word huh quickly they
disappeared
I mean you ran off there on that in that
direction is he still looking off to the
right there underneath is well that was
quick
oh goodness yes the stalking leopard
yoga pose I've never tried that one I
would probably pull something but he is
damn it indeed unfortunately that one
didn't pay off but he gave it a very
good girl and I think he did incredibly
well in getting as close as he did and
suddenly the tension has been released
but he's not looking too happy with
himself not that he did anything to did
anything to miss his attempts up but
obviously one of those sets of four eyes
and caught that movement I think while I
catch my breath and maybe try and
stretch and move around a little bit
laughter we can do that without
affecting horse on his hunt I'll send
you back to past history what he's up to
that's like to be put on the edge by
hassanis Oh bad luck for the little
chief but well hopefully that isn't
discouraging for him and he does
continue to try and get himself a feat
that he can hang on to and actually eat
himself he wasn't looking well he would
definitely wasn't looking like you had
had a feed recently when I saw him
yesterday his stomach was looking at a
bit flat so I really do hope he can
secure himself a meal but he's got all
of our support and I'm sure he will but
just very good to
very good to have him back and very good
that he didn't actually get chased off
the property by the Lions it seems like
it's been quite the opposite actually
the Lions have gone off the property and
husana has stuck around so I've gone
down south at the moment because I
haven't been down this way for a little
bit of kind of in up around the northern
side of the property over the last few
days or so and I'm just having a look it
seems like there was a few elephants
somewhat recently in the area there's
some tracks around some dung some
broken-down trees so just kind of having
a look around for that because I still
haven't gotten my herd yet I've gotten
single male elephants on three different
occasions now but as for a full herd
itself has been something that has
eluded me despite of the size of those
giants hope grant does stick with husana
and a hope that he does go for another
hunt
it is something we did see quite a bit a
few months ago was husana going for a
few hunts in the matter of the space of
a drive so it's not like he will just go
for one and then stop hopefully he does
continue to remove the base and try and
get himself an Impala definitely his
prey of choice in something that
leopards do go for a lot is the Impala
it's kind of that perfect size for them
and as for speed well as you probably
all saw then they do have to get very
very close to an impalas usually within
about you know five metres or so to
launch the strike and be able to keep up
let's have a look here this is a cool no
it's gonna fly off let's see if it lands
yes it did great go away bird bird we
frequently hear out here in the bush out
Ian no I haven't seen any zebra at all
since I have been back looks like it's
flowing off there anyway I haven't seen
any any at all any zebra
I just before saw a giraffe but
unfortunately like those lions crossed
into buffers hook so it was already
across the northern boundary when we saw
it and then it ran off will not ran off
but it was only quite a bit of a mission
it almost seemed like it suspected
something was in the area perhaps even
those Lions it looked a little bit on
edge we know that we didn't really get
up close to it but it was constantly on
the move the whole time we were around
it but that was the first giraffe I've
also seen since being back in Juma of
course a different species than the ones
that I would always see up in the Mara
that was a giraffe a Tibbles sketchy or
the Masai giraffe and down here we get
the southern giraffe as your Arthur
jirafa that's right draft being quiet
well not quite a bit but a little bit
taller the tallest species in in Africa
okay well I've just done a big loop and
haven't been able to pick up on anything
else would like me to send you back over
to Jamie whilst I try and find it
something cool to look at
no not come afraid our big loop was
locked by a hunting husana that's the
route that we wanted to go because
that's where we think the Lions might
have gone but obviously you know we're
not gonna walk straight into the middle
of an established leopard sighting while
he's hunting Impala that would be really
truly horrible
they were just strolling really and
admiring this absolutely iconic looking
Marilla tree this time of year of course
they don't have leaves saving up all of
their energy for when summer returns
once again and they have to bear fruit
this is this the perfect Leopard tree
you really feel as though there should
be a leopard spread over the branches
but I've tried to lie in marula trees
before and I have to tell you that it is
phenomenally uncomfortable we see it
leopards sleeping on the ground so often
and we regularly get asked why they
don't sleep more in the trees they do
but it's really not comfortable it's
actually really really not comfortable
they make it look comfortable but I
think even for them it starts to get a
bit hmm
I'm trying to think of a synonym for
uncomfortable I can't think of one now
curse words to know if I've ever seen a
leopard fall out of a tree while
sleeping I haven't unfortunately I have
heard stories of it happening though
I've heard stories of leopards
stretching and just flopping out of the
tree they're usually quite good at
recovering it though they usually sort
of Scrabble their way along I'm trying
to think we've seen we have seen house
I'm talking nonsense we've seen hasana
fall out of the trees before multiple
times but never while he was asleep it
was usually because he was doing
something silly while he was growing up
you know he was jumping from one tree to
another and he just sort of tumbled out
of it mm-hmm but I've never seen I've
never seen a leopard sleeping and
rolling out of a tree I think it might
be quite entertaining to watch as long
as they didn't hurt themselves you get
it with cats sometimes I seen my cat
fall off the couch stretching and
rolling over in the Sun and just so
overjoyed that she was experiencing this
nap time and she just stretched roll
over and you know fall off the couch and
like any cat
leopards would be able to land on their
feet
mm-hmm somebody had a merry time here
I'm gonna go with honey badger that
would be my guess something very fluffy
speaking of fluffy things we're gonna
send you across to Pat who has found the
fluffiest of all fluffy antelope okay so
I'm just sorry yeah I just was blocking
the road before a vehicle that was
actually a police vehicle hopefully I
didn't do anything wrong so I'm just
gonna go back yeah we are here with some
water buck and some Impala actually is
the main focus this one here being a
female obviously distinct by the lack of
horns and well speaking before about how
we have a different species of giraffe
up in the Mara than what we have it down
here and well it's also the same well
not species sorry Oh different
subspecies so the subspecies we had up
in the Mara is the de faster water buck
and they had this this this ring we see
on the bum here is actually absent in
the Mara in the de fossa water buck but
these ones he is obviously present and
it serves the function as a bit of a
follow me it helps to guide other water
back through this dense kind of bushes
they are so frequently found in yeah
Conrad a tech guy I'm not gonna disclose
that why but he has earned himself the
nickname water buck
varta Bucky and well yeah as I said the
story you might have to get from him
yourself anyway I just saw that stuff
where you can have a quick look at them
as they did at link so nicely with the
juror
sure a few of you would be aware of the
hunt last week with the water buck and
the wild dogs very cool stuff for rusty
to have seen before he left and well I
think that's the first ever time I have
seen or heard of a water buck being
hunted by a carnivores they're
definitely not the preferred prey of
animals and well I've heard I'm not sure
if this is any truth behind this but
I've heard it's because there is a bit
of a a suppression in their meat and
also on their fur that is quite
repulsive to other animals but obviously
didn't bother these wild dogs in the
slightest they absolutely devoured at
that thing at the moment whoa I couldn't
really pick back up on anything of the
elephants I couldn't heat or anything
but well husana we as a same does prefer
an Impala I don't know whether he would
go yet for a water buck but let's go and
catch up with the little chief and grant
Pat I do think horse Anna would take
quite kindly to a water back meal at
this stage even with the annoying oil
that they have in their skin because of
all the hard work that he just put into
this hunt did not provide him with any
reward unfortunately but anyways he
doesn't let that get to him he will
carry on with the resilience that only a
lipid has when it comes to hunting and
he has just moved further up the edge of
this drainage line and we won't actually
see him at the moment so there are some
other guys trying to have a look on the
other side but I think we might have to
just loop around here to try and see if
we can find him again yeah shame hard
work or friend yeah but that's usually
the kind of work that that pays off come
on Wendy let's get up here
excellent
yeah and so he will keep trying the
direction that he moved out of the
strange line
I heard M L Impala sort of ratting that
writing sound that they make I know we
were talking about the impalas sounds
earlier and I'm pretty sure that he
heard the same sound that I heard and
may have moved up in that direction to
go and have a look and see what they're
up to and I'll just try and finish off
on that that story from earlier about
the Impala sounds being three altogether
the one snorting sound the three sounds
being the snort is the alarm call the
rutting sort of gargling sound that
we've just heard and then the sound that
the carves or lamb sorry that the Impala
lambs make when they're very young okay
he yep he you sort of a contact or very
gentle kind of grunting sound Adamic
between them and their mothers there was
a question about how many stalks end in
a kill and that actually varies quite a
bit from predator to predator say
so just that was a pretty good question
um it sounds a percentage when it comes
to leopards they are probably successful
around surprisingly about 30 or 40
percent of the time which isn't very
much obviously it varies from situation
to situation different habitats wind and
all the sort of factors that we were
talking about earlier that I'm sure
hasanul is thinking about now the most
successful predators in terms of hunt to
kill ratio would be the African wild
painted dog as they're more accurately
known and they usually get into the
region of about seventy percent success
rate and that probably has a lot to do
with the fact that they hunt as a group
whereas leopards all the time would be
hunting on their own so that puts them
in a completely different kind of
environment when they're hunting they
can't rely on anybody else to help them
so yeah their percentage does drop quite
a bit Lions also sort of in the region
of about forty percent or so
all right I think he may have come up in
this direction we were parked I'm just
trying to look for a marker with these
trees that we were looking at but I
think he was somewhere down here from
where we were sitting and I don't think
he would come right out into the open
it's just as he was heading in the
opposite direction to what I'm facing
now so oh there he is
he's about 1 o'clock now moving over to
the right just in front of us there that
was a lucky spot he just moved through a
little gap as I looked as I looked in
that direction so let me just go back
towards this other open patch here and
we'll try and see if we can get a few
glimpses of him moving through this
vegetation on the edge of the drainage
line here
b10 ghana I don't know actually when
lost in Ghana was seen unfortunately and
I haven't been lucky enough to see it in
Ghana yet so I know that Hasan has only
been back in the area for was about
three days or so now and that tail as we
mentioned earlier ok Tuesday I believe
he was seen on Drive last week Tuesday
even know what date is today what every
Monday Tuesday about a week ago Winton
garner was seen so whether he's in the
area or not I don't know
but he um asana seems to be quite calm
at the moment so there's not too much
competition around for him
at least for now sorry I believe it's
Sunday excuse my ignorance of the days
of the week but that tends to happen
quite easily but other days don't really
change very much although every day is
different
they sunrise and sunset and good times
in between I see him just over to the
left you think he's actually gonna cross
the road here just in front of us trying
not DIF myself get in the way I know you
can't see him just yet but he was
looking looking across the road and I'm
almost certain that he was looking for
for those importers a little bit forward
here oh here he comes
Darius nice look at that light on him
but if you can hear the Franklin's
hopefully you can Franklin's are
chirping chirping away that's their
alarm call they've seen a lipid it's a
good sound to remember that sort of
chirping of the Franklin's it'll often
point you in the direction of something
like a leopard or another predator I'm
just gonna update everybody else who is
understandably trying to keep up with us
on it he's quite a character stations or
Sun has just crossed south over twin
dams Road sort of hitting the south
easterly direction due to my 3 o'clock
all right while we try and keep up with
husana as he meanders through the bushes
yeah hopefully comes across the moor in
parlours and we'll send you a cross to
catch up with Jamie
I was thinking the same thing you know
about ting gana was wondering where it
is that he's gone apparently there were
tracks around waffles hook cut line this
morning it's interesting isn't it
that's his arrival of his son he he
hasn't moved off he's probably just
doing his regular territorial route I
suppose but be interesting to see what
happens I think that initial interaction
was based purely on another leopard now
the male and horse on Iran and ting
Ghana came in and it just was a bit
confused I don't think he knew which
leopard it was I think he just responded
and husana having spent so much time
seeing other male leopards that didn't
welcome him ran away so I don't know I
don't know where ting gone is gone what
I do know is this was once upon a time a
very tall tree and I was about to sit on
it and so I realized it is almost it's
actually not completely hollow I would
have been surprised if it were
completely Hollow but the bark or at
least the cambium layer has now fallen
away and a lot of it split off from the
heartwood and this was a knob thorn once
at the pot a time and it must have been
I mean if I come down towards the roots
two three four five okay not the most
accurate weeks seven eight nine ten ten
ish I mean some of the branches are
broken off 10 ish meters in height and
what's fascinating I always find about
that and this isn't the best example cuz
it's quite an old tree but how shallow
the root systems are of nob thorns so
one of the reasons why they say you
shouldn't put your camp up underneath a
knob thorn tree especially during storm
season because there's a they often blow
over they have very very shallow root
systems this most of the roots have
rotted away but you can sort of get an
idea this roots extended to about here
that's about three meters worth of long
root maybe three meters on that one as
well
mmm I need to sneeze I'm sorry I'm going
to come and go so a lot to support the
weight of a 10 metre tree and the thing
about nob thorn
is that the wood is incredibly thick not
incredibly thinking could it be dense
now like laid wood
very very heavy very solid tree and for
a big old tree like this if you were to
get a square meter of this heartwood
you'd probably looking at around about
800 kilograms for one square for one
cubic meter of solid wood that's a lot
that's nearly as much as a lid word
which is about a ton per cubic meter
which is why of course lid wood sinks
something that shocked the people who
tried to use them as railway sleepers
because they chopped down the Paul
Edwards Chuck them into the river and
they all went and sank as such solid
wood but not thorn is to makes very good
firewood it's also more suitable than
dead wood because of course they're not
endangered so you're not going to get
into trouble if you were to cut one down
we're led wood you cannot you also
cannot cut up big fallen dead lead wood
either because it um it is it forms such
an important part of the ecosystem and
it survives for hundreds of years even
when it's dead Emma says it makes a good
balancing beam it does although of
course not many gymnasts have to face
the reality of a potential spitting
cobra coming out of the woodwork ha hmm
but yes he does I just find it
fascinating to think that it's supported
by such a shallow root system yes a
whole new level to them gymnastics for
the Olympics you know the balancing beam
with a spitting cobra that pops out at
random intervals be a little bit unfair
although you've might might make the
jumps much higher Barbara wants to know
how they survive droughts with such
shallow roots it's an interesting one
they and they can also grow in places
where the soil is very very dry sorrow
still needs to sneeze quite desperately
blame Aly she bought back a cold poor
thing mm-hmm
they can I guess that they they get
sufficient water clearly they do because
they grow it's interesting about them is
that their nitrogen
fix's which means that they can they
have a symbiotic with relationship with
bacteria that allows them to get hold of
nitrogen or nitrogen as an element is
obviously extremely common in the
atmosphere so 70 plus percent of our
atmosphere but at the same time it is a
very stable compound a very stable
molecule so the bonds formed between two
nitrogen atoms very very strong which
makes nitrogen getting nitrogen into our
any living organism and it's an
essential part of a living organism is a
difficult one and going from certain
Nate and nitrates and nitrites and
getting it into a soluble form so
something that can dissolve in water
that's hydrophilic here's a tricky thing
and things like not thorns and other
acacia so all the caches anymore but you
know what I mean
are nitrogen fixers which means they
have these incredible systems within
their roots that's not absolutely
nothing to do with water but that's
because the truth is I don't know how
they managed to get their water with
such shallow root systems they obviously
managed it's just interesting that they
grow in the places that they grow where
a marula tree doesn't cannot fix
nitrogen but it does have relatively
deep roots all right I'm in desperate
need of a sneeze so while I attempt to
do so let's hit across a two-horse sauna
and see whether or not he's got any dust
up his nose
alright thanks Jamie um we are busy
following Hassan at the moment he's
directly in front of me at the moment
I'm just gonna switch often and watch
him walk past in front he's kind of
moving up in a sort of southwesterly
direction and stopping every now and
then and listening and looking around
for those rutting impalas the fact that
he went straight from one unsuccessful
hunt and into another means that he is
quite keen and if you look just in front
of his back legs there is Billy you'll
see that it's quite narrow you'll see
when a leopard has had a big meal it'll
be kind of ballooned out quite
noticeably when he's fooled himself up
but at the moment he's very intent on
trying to find another meal you don't
want to lose visual of him for too long
is knowing how good they are at
disappearing they'll give us the slip
very very quickly so let's just flip
through here you see how he's gone into
some thick grass all right I see him on
the other side day that's good oh look
at that termite man there
it's hopefully gonna go and lie up on
top of that termite month now I know
some of you are wondering if I have a
favorite lipid sighting you know that is
you know I'm probably in a very
fortunate position to have to sift
through quite a number of sightings yeah
let's try get ourselves into a nice
position here
cuz this will turn into another nice
sighting think so I've only ever
actually been lucky enough to see one
full leopard hunt which ended in a kill
and that was with a female leopard down
in the south known as slab on Quincy
just gonna stop here I don't know what's
on the other side of this termite mud I
just want him to have a look around and
then see what he decides to do good he's
laying down so let's start up and go
around so we've got a little bit of
better light on his face there and it
looks like this is how we are going to
enjoy our sunset this afternoon
spectacular sure other lipid sightings
that would stand out as favorites it
would be the very fortunate position I
was in also even longer even longer back
then in the slab on Quincy sighting but
with a female leopard down in the East
or southeast of the sabi sands was a
female leopard known as the knuckles dry
female and she at the time that I worked
there which was in a very long time had
a cub who when I arrived was four months
old and
during the time that I was there I got
to watch her raise this cub he had the
most wonderful character was very
playful and took every opportunity to
learn from his very experienced mother
so not one particular sighting but many
courtesy of the yuckles try female just
look at that and now you can probably
understand why and it's quite hard to
decide on my favorite lipid sighting you
can see that double collar that I was
talking about earlier or double necklace
that he's got there absolutely gorgeous
I just look so regal and they're perched
up on top of a termite mound like that
wonder if they share the same
appreciation for a sunset as we do it
would be in a perfect position to enjoy
it where he is there and the Sun sits
west of us behind some gorilla trees
leaves already like classic winter Sun
sit down in the low fault this time and
also provide him with a very good
vantage point to look out for threats
which would probably be less prolific at
the moment then hunting opportunities
but it's a good spot to look out for
both of those and although he is right
up and quite obvious at the moment his
camouflage does still help blend him
into the grass especially if you're not
particularly looking for a leopard you
might just miss him
that has become a habit of mine to
continuously check on the top of any
large termite mounds that I'm driving
past because it is a brilliant place to
see a leopard sir it's not always very
common but you should be very hopeful
that it actually does happen and our son
is playing the game nicely today look at
those eyes yeah
it's beautiful
everybody is quite fond of his pink nose
I did have a closer look at it earlier
since I can zoom in in there they might
be able to see the few scratches that he
starting to pick up it doesn't make him
any less beautiful just signs that his
experience is growing in life now if you
do a bit of reading you might find that
some descriptions of lipids appearance
might indicate that or say that a pink
nose indicates that it's a younger lipid
and then it usually blackens with age
but some lepers don't pedal and might
see that around the edges of his nose
and has blackened a little bit but I
think in hopes that he will keep that
beautiful pink nose of his
just look at the reflections in his eyes
at the moment as well and one or two
flies they're not buzzing around on his
head you know this is amazing indeed
it's almost as if those swaying grass
stalks sort of add to the beautiful
atmosphere of such a regal creature
those gears
well then indeed sensor sensor no sign
of working as a solid team to deliver
some excellent visuals for everybody
this afternoon and I get to sit and
enjoy it with you which is very very
lucky and much appreciated indeed
cool so while we sit back and relax with
a sauna and enjoy the sunset we'll send
you back to continue your search with
that
yes still very much looking around at
the moments I did abandon my search for
the elephants and well those down around
none of them were southern water holes
and I did see tracks for what looked to
be a large male leopard I could really
only put it down to perhaps 10 Ghana and
then there was also a tiny little
leopard tracks around just north of
where we were which kind of looked a lot
like insula lumber so the tree must have
been in this area at some stage so I'm
just kind of looking around it looked
like both trucks one was going kind of
into the mall RT and one was coming out
of the mulatto MA which is a dry
riverbed that kind of runs through
almost south to north in the property
and well I've come a little bit far out
from there now as I said there were
tracks coming out and this is the
direction they were heading they were to
the lumbers who I think is told it looks
like a very small female leopard and
since then haven't really come back up
on anything so I think what I'm going to
do is double back and actually head down
I did do the last southern portion of
the moitie I went down into the river oh
well who could Morey hasn't been seen
for quite a while now it's been if I had
to guess perhaps two weeks yeah
so as for where he is actually gone I'm
not sure and it would be interesting to
see him or let's just look at this
sunset for a second this is insane so he
was yeah I mean sorry it would have been
interesting if he was around though to
see how he responded to husana coming
back but since the little chief has been
back huka Moria has not been seen so I'm
not exactly sure which property he
crossed which direction he went in but
he's kind of someone who does come and
go quite a bit but how good is this so
the way the Sun is sitting behind the
clouds right
now we can see that it's it's almost
hard to look at the clouds the way it's
reflecting the sunlight it's very very
very golden and as that Sun that starts
to descend it's going to get a lot
cooler out here things as we are in the
winter months and I think what I'm going
to do is have a bit more of a search
around and the more arty see if I can
pick up on Tenggara
Auto a llama and then I reckon they go
it will be to be headed through the
hyena den so on we move
I'm just hearing on the game drive radio
that there is a three-year-old tawny
eagle up a bull's hoof but it's just a
bit far away for us to traverse up that
way so with that in mind let's send you
back over to grant and husana to see
what the little chief is up to now sana
is indeed still perched up in the
termite mound enjoying the sunset and
listening very intently to what's going
on around him if you watch his ears
you'll see him swinging them backwards
and forwards as he looks around in all
different directions he's got a nice 360
degree view from up there you just watch
his nose every now and then he might
lift its nut into the air and pick up on
any smells that might be drifting in on
this easterly breeze that were enjoying
similar to yesterday evening some alerts
yesterday evening when everything starts
quietening down you know there's very
gentle sun's starting to develop as the
evening goes on so he's sitting on his
elbow there
I'm getting a little bit of a background
they behind him as well the few clouds
in the sky but nothing too bad
binoculars
see I've never spent this much time with
my son and it's nice to just to get to
know all of his little markings the spot
patterns that make up his unique
identity that he will keep for life in
us one of the last things about the fact
that leopards never change their spots
which is absolutely true and I think
many viewers probably do know what horse
owners spot pattern is and what exactly
a spot pattern is but if you did have a
look at him you'll see that on on each
side of his snout on the top line of his
whiskers he's got some spots that are
unique to him and on once on hosannas
cheeks
he's got three on his right and three on
his left so I would say that his spot
pattern is 3 3 so whenever you get that
sort of first glance of a leopard and
not too sure who he is or she is it's a
good idea to just lift your binaries and
have a look at those spots on his face
that'll usually give them away I was
looking at photos of who was it it was
calamba this morning and also just
trying to identify her and it is quite
apparent when you i've spent a bit of
time with lipids how unique each of them
are part of their ID also goes along
with the area that you find them in as
lipids a very very territorial and
females occupying a particularly small
area
and so other science yes other signs
that you could use to identify a leopard
I was just mentioning the territories so
that is one thing that you can use for
sure because that changes sort of over
liquids lifetime but over a long period
of time during their lives it's usually
quite solid so a male leopard to have a
fairly large territory and a female a
slightly smaller territory looks like
he's gonna spend a little bit more time
on top of the termite mound gives me a
good chance to explain
so yes territories so the area you find
them in would usually give them away as
well and then other markings or physical
signs on their bodies so Tinga no sanas
pink nose would be one so the pink nose
associated with the three three spot
pattern would give him away and as he
gets older he will pick up a few more
scars and things from fights or
territorial confrontations that he might
have with other lipids or hyenas or more
lions hopefully not too much of that and
if you look at the the shape of the edge
of the ears particularly when he's
sitting up looking straight at you and
his ears are pricked up you can see the
edge of the ear would also and give away
part of their idea if they've got a
little bit of a notch or a tear in the
earlobe you can also use that to
identify them I'm sure many of you
probably know ribbon the hyena with a
very big tear in her left yeah and for
those of you who don't she is a fairly
well known hyena in this area and one of
the ways of identifying her is her big
tear in her left yeah overall appearance
in terms of leopards especially with
lions it does get quite tricky with
lions because they don't have unique
spot patterns as they don't have any
spots but their overall appearance or
some lines a slightly darker shade
overall
their coat mail lines and males might
have very big Mane's so I might have
very pale mains or very dark means are
you just yeah I think the more time you
spend with with these animals and and
the individuals you kind of forced to
look for there how do you call it there
particulars of each individual I
remember there was a leopard yeah I
don't want to get this wrong but I lip
it down in the south who had a kink in
his tail which he obviously picked up in
a fight or some sort of confrontation
possibly in a hunt or something and and
we used that to identify him his name
eludes me at the motors either the
nearly 80 male or the kishan male
anyways I will search here and ponder
that for a while while more silent naps
on the termite manner will send you back
to Jaime to enjoy the sunset
now while animals keep their looks to a
certain degree throughout their lives
each and every single sunset is
different how tenuous was that
connection there was an effort though I
made the effort to connect it all up
connect the dots and really is a
beautiful sunset my word it's
spectacular it feels like there's every
single color of the spectrum up there
including the blue of that egg that we
saw earlier I feel like that blue is in
there somewhere
a little bit of purple a little bit of
pink a little bit of gold oh it's just
getting better Birds egg blue hmm worth
every now and then stopping just to
watch the sunset although probably less
Sun walk when you're not quite close to
camp and a lot of you know have you
wondering if I sneezed apparently quite
concerned you know II just think about
this as both safe and I started at
almost exactly the same time he started
the beginning of Drive and I started a
halfway through the walk so we're a
little bit convinced Tristen sounds as
though somebody put gravel rocks in his
voice box this morning his voiceovers
for spy lights are going to be hilarious
and he doesn't exactly have a high
pitched voice at the best of times and
said that myself live in the same house
as the contagious twosome the what do we
call them
the contagious couple the contagious
couple the Spirit is willing but the
body is a bin liner filled with yogurt
this afternoon I really wish that was my
line but it's not it was Stephen Fry's
but I feel it is perfectly apt
description did I sneeze no his his my
nose running yes subdued Tandy's tracks
we think might beetle umbers walking
along down weavers nest road and sim and
I have just been having a discussion
along with Kirby as to what we do with
tracks it's our new favorite game Kirby
and myself we have a little competition
as to who can step on old tracks first
but we will call these and I think
because they do you look as though
they're sort of from at some point this
afternoon so the front foot here fast
walking really fast
front foot here and in the back track
here these little toesies so from the
same point on each track it's a distance
of about probably close on was that four
or five inches she's walking fast
missioning he essentially you find that
when the back track and this is not a
hill sometimes really you're on a
downward slope the back track obviously
overtakes their front track just cause
of gravity and putting their body down
but this is a flat road so we're going
to stomp on them this is what's seven I
were calling this a formatting the road
like you format a memory card and that
when the road is graded it is they it is
a factory reset of the whole area anyway
that's about as nearly as safe and I get
let's go across to Patrick who probably
doesn't appreciate the fact that we're
stepping all over his tracks
well now I'm not looking for trucks now
I'm listening out for alarm calls so we
heard from Tristan that there are impala
alarm calling not too far from
quarantine and so I'm just come up that
way to you have a look around now both
sets of tracks although they were
heading kind of into the river
they were also heading in a northward
direction which is the direction we have
come in and so it could be that a
leopard has made its way up from the
south that's we'll just have a bit of it
okay so I can see some Impala over here
I wonder if these are the ones that were
calling
so there's definitely some Impala around
I haven't heard any noise yet though
let's just switch off for a second and
have a bit of a listen out just sit here
for a couple of minutes see if I can
hear anything sometimes it is a little
bit difficult to hear over the sound of
the engine and also over the sound of my
own voice echoing through the back of my
skull
[Music]
no sounds as if yet
Tristan did say gin seemed like super
serious alarming
it wasn't anything crazy but definitely
worth coming up to have a look anyway
okay well yeah maybe you're right Emma
maybe they were just having a bit of a
chat but whatever this it doesn't seem
to be occurring anymore
not to worry so it's always worth
following up on alarm calls most of the
time
I mean trucks definitely do help but
unless you have had years and years and
years of experience to be able to
accurately age a track is a very
difficult thing so they can be good for
showing I tend to use them as a guide
for the general area and not specific
directions but sound on the other hand
alarm calls have been very very helpful
in the past in kind of being a bit more
specific in it locating where an animal
is well even last night with husana
those squirrels after he gave us the
slip led us directly to him Joyce I have
seen in Impala alarming at hyenas I saw
it in the Mara but I have also seen
hyenas walk past Impala without a alarm
call but a lot of the time you will hear
them alarming because I Eanes will hunt
impala a lot of people think of hyenas
only as scavengers but they do tend to
hunt a lot as well even in the Mara
I saw them attempting some zebra
although it wasn't really attempting
that which is kind of fishing they were
chasing the zebras but not really giving
proper chases just to see if any sick or
wounded or young or slow were in the
pack or the herd sorry okay well someone
else that plenty of things alarm at as I
was just saying is Hassan oh let's go
back to the little chief who is still
very relaxed on a termite mound
quiet indeed pet hisana is appreciating
the silence I'm sure after chasing those
and parlors of although the ones that
see what he's doing
ones that he was listening for have gone
quiet as well
he's just set up again just as you guys
came back to me which is good timing
he's looking off either he's gazing at
the beautiful sunset always actually
heard something I didn't hear anything
but he's definitely heard something in
the distance there if he had seen
something he might have popped his head
up and opened his eyes a little bit
wider so he's little sort of behavioral
cruise clues or sometimes give away what
he's thinking he's just scanning around
trying to pick up on any information
that might lead to his next hunt I was
thinking a little bit earlier on that he
might be waiting for it to get dark
before he starts to try and hunt again
the hardy I do think he will eventually
head back towards the the Jimmer camp he
tends to go in these sort of short
forays and then works his way back
towards probably where he feels safe
around camp and after an encounter like
last night maybe he's still a little bit
shaken but still quite determined to
look for a meal so I'm hoping that he
does come back does make it quite a bit
easier to find him if he does decide to
do that but while we've been following
him this afternoon
oh it's just us a cold shoulder um well
we've been following him this afternoon
he has been walking away from the we are
Taylor dam and damn cam sorry I'm just
gonna try and move yet don't want to
shake around too much
there we go he's obviously just switched
back to listen back down towards the
drainage line where he came from just
see if anything presents itself in that
direction nice clouds developing down
there as well giving us a nice sort of
painted sky to look at and as you'll see
behind him the sky starting to darkened
the Sun dips below the horizon on the
one side it costs a shadow up into the
sky on the other side but you can sit
here and watch as it grows and grows it
is gorgeous
now this is going more into the time of
day sorry time of night when leopards do
prefer to move around and doing their
hunting so the hunt earlier on hunt
earlier on I think he just stumbled upon
those impalas and they're very
opportunistic in that way way they will
try and take advantage of whatever
opportunity that they come across but in
terms of conditions they will definitely
try and use the darkness to their
advantage now our sight is incredible in
the dark much much better than ours and
slightly better than slightly better
than the antelope and other species and
I think a star does have us a loose
schedule he definitely doesn't chase his
watch as much as what we after you
it's a very loose schedule I suppose
what matters to him is his safety
eventually reproducing and along the way
trying to find a meal so wherever and
whenever those opportunities arise they
will try and take advantage of it
orange how long he lost without a meal
if if you mean how long he'll survive by
by the word last it's hard to say I mean
I've watched leopards with without
getting a major meal so a meal that
would fill them up for periods of
probably two weeks and that's just my
experience of what I've seen I could
probably go if I had to guess a bit
longer than that maybe three weeks
before they really start losing
condition and and energy but yeah I
would guess sort of two weeks ideally
they would kill something every three or
four days depending how big their last
meal was and in those situations where I
watched lipids for two weeks or so
without any major meal there might also
take smaller things in between so lipids
are incredibly versatile with their
menus and they they'll take anything
from beetles up to small rodents or
birds and anything up to the size of
buffalo calves and things of that nature
so they're very very versatile versatile
and for that reason can usually survive
in a vast range of habitats and even in
areas that are very very close to human
habitats yeah
also I think in the meantime while we
sit here and see if he's gonna make any
moves we'll send you back to Jamie who I
believe is also quite versatile and her
tracking abilities I do like us on
another sitar I am but I can squash 9
tracks that one too and that one and I
saw one here too now I know that's her
B's check there that one and that one
because everything looks are fresh at
this time of year that we are out let me
get my shoe okay I think I got it
sorry straighten the arch no I haven't
got it you advise you it's a little
spiky thing I mean it's probably a grass
seed it's my fault for getting the
Gators there we go hmm I really am
genuinely doing this for a specific
purpose and that's because everything
looks so fresh at this time of year and
this this sort of the soil is so dry
that it's worth just marking out what's
old and what's new so that we don't have
any mistakes speaking of which who lions
- lioness has went south again which is
what we thought we finally found their
tracks on weavers nest I suspect now
long gone I'm also just bumped into one
of the juma clan members unfortunately a
little bit too far away for me to figure
out who it was
that she ran who he ran across down here
hyenas don't really like seeing people
on foot you can't have bitumen but
because of their intelligent levels it's
probably better that we don't because
they end up you know it's one thing
having an animal that interacts
regularly with a human camp they often
come into our camp and they often come
looking for any scraps because human
beings leave scraps it's just one of
those things about how cautious you are
they often find themselves getting lucky
with the dust but the rubbish bin if it
hasn't been put inside
now if you have [ __ ] you ate them two
people on foot when they become
dangerous
what do you hear lions I can't hear
anything because my ears are working
nothing maybe Suzie heard of lion
that's I believe him I didn't though we
marching
now back towards camp as it gets dark
obviously the sun's gone down and at
this time of year it gets dark very
quickly I'm hoping that those three
elephant balls that we saw this morning
I was with Michelle and then of course
Steve and Herbie saw them on foot again
but later I'm hoping that they might
come down towards the dam for a quick
drink it's possible however you got
these tracks already and leopard tracks
tiny tracks it's a fun game in kirby's
winning though he was up ahead of me but
we're hoping that those elephant balls
might come down to have a drink cause
it's a much water elsewhere so well we
very lethargically
have a competition to see who can squash
the most tracks or solder is out and
about on Juma making more
Oh energetic I don't the moment he looks
clean but definitely taking it easy
I believe Jamie was discussing
habituating hyenas with everybody
and although yeah it can sometimes be
dangerous but excuse me always coming
towards us habituating leopards I
suppose that could be um similar in some
ways where I mean we would call husana
perfectly habituated if you look how
close he just walked right past us so
this can provide incredibly good side
things like that and it's always such a
good feeling when they when they just
take no notice of your neuro so allows
us to watch them as they would be
without us even being there which is
ideal the only thing it can put cause
sometimes is that they do come to a
little bit too close to you which if you
react in the right way is fine
but otherwise that could sometimes
sometimes put you a little bit too close
anyways I don't want to ignore him for
too long let's just try and turn around
there's a big stump there in front of us
thank you sins Oh second eyes quite
important winter let me navigate through
yet
cool I wonder if he actually did just
hear something
and is he charting Hey
let's just try and keep up with him
apparently he's just picked up his pace
a little bit and my main priority here
looks like a nasty sickle Bush can't
drive over there um I think it might
have something it could have something
to do with the Lions I'll have to watch
him a little bit and just try and see if
it looks like he's worried about
something or if he's interested in
something that's if I do manage to find
him again did you see where he went
Singler okay cool and it could as Herbie
mentioned that he had seen the Lions I
was watching asana to see what his
reaction was and he he didn't sort of
react it immediately but he did sort of
glance up in a direction lifting his
ears up and so you may have heard those
lines but if the Lions are far enough
away which they were because I didn't
get anything at all then he wouldn't
react as instantly of what he did not um
so I think he may have just reacted to
either hearing something that he might
be interested in eating or something
along those lines but while I try and
catch up with him again as I have lost
visual of him I'll send you back to cat
for a short walk
we'll see you just now with husana as
for me well I did hang around just a
little bit longer to see if there was
any alarming or anything of the sorts
but unfortunately nothing more to be
heard now I'm just kind of sort of
heading down around where you would have
seen Jamie found at tondee's tracks just
before well I heard from Herbie anyway
all over the radio that tardies trucks
were down around kind of in the south as
well where I also thought I saw it in
Donna's track Santa llamas as well so I
think it makes sense to kind of head
back down in that direction and try and
use this last bit of gold and light
my advantage hopefully get some
last-minute leopard spectacular as great
as it has been catching up with Hassan
pretty much since he has been here it
has all been about him which i think is
fair enough we have missed him we all
need our doses him but since that's
little scuffle between him Tenggara
haven't seen ting ghana
and it was also the last time I saw a
trial umba she was well the first one in
that sighting and didn't seem to be too
affected by it all but having said that
I also didn't see her after this eye
thing so I'm not sure whether she got
scared off by her son Ian can can
leopards inherit things from their
parents well yes they inherit everything
from their parents just as you and I do
all of their genetics come from the
sperm of the father and the egg of the
mother and well they get a pretty much
50/50 mix as they get one a strand from
each animal I mean from each sex one
strand of DNA making a tree in total and
so that splits the genes 5050 and so
they can get half things from their dad
and half the things from their mother
just like in us human so this can be
personality traits this going to also be
physical traits size shape certain may
be mutations perhaps so for example just
a random example of this maybe that one
might have been born with three toes say
and then there's always such a chance
that if that was a genetic thing that it
could be passed on to the next
generation so everything is passed down
from the parents to the Cubs and we can
see this a little bit between Tandy and
fuller lumber
she definitely has that little bit of
attitude to lumber it doesn't seem to be
as bad as tarney but then having said
that Tandy is also quite an older cat
there's Columbia hasn't had that life
experience yet
and well to be honest I haven't seen
well obviously I've never seen per Ola
in the flesh so I'm not sure but you
guys tell me what you think does anyone
think that there's any resemblance
between hasanah
and Kerala especially those that were
watching quite a bit back in the day or
anyone that doesn't know what Kerala
looks like I'd like to hear your
opinions to see if you think that you do
see any similarities marine FC is saying
that they both had spots well yes yes
that definitely is a similarity but I
mean keeping the trait very clever there
Moz okay well I think what I'm gonna
doing now
Barbara is saying that all of cooler's
offspring that seem to have small traits
that kind of do resemble her in a way
which it does make sense I mean it
really is just like you may see in
someone's son or daughter you may see
that they have their dad's eyes and
their mums mouth that's all from the
fusion of genetics what an interesting
thing to actually read up on and and
follow obviously it's an integral part
of any sort of biological education and
so it was hammered into us during high
school and university
yeah taking a different well usually I
come out of Lehigh in this way but I'm
going in at this time well someone who
I'm sure has her own opinions on the
Silverado he's similarities between
Corolla and Hasani is a Jamie so let's
go see what her take is on the subject I
do have plenty of opinions but in terms
more specifically of coruña and husana I
don't think what Sanne looks like her
ulla but I do think he looks like
Haruna's male offspring if that makes
sense he looks like his brothers I think
he bears a lot of resemblance
structurally to your leopard like
quarantine I didn't really get to see
kanuma all that often
quarantines brother I saw him once or
twice and very briefly but I do think he
looks like warned a little bit like
quarantine Tandi on the other hand looks
like Garuda and not only that tündi and
shadow were so clearly sisters I know
we've been over this a few times
recently but specifically it's in my
mind because of the the Panthera camera
trap project and looking at the genetic
inheritance of physical traits within
leopards but Tony and shadow really
really looked similar in fact the
pointer when I first saw Tony I thought
of a shadow because I'd only ever seen
shadowed was before the time that we
used to traverse anywhere down south or
to the east so I'd never seen Tandy
before she'd come in to mate with ting
Ghana and shadow I had seen regularly
because we used to spend a lot of time
on arethusa and she had Cindy de there
so I sort of a shadow when I first saw
her whoops there's a tree they said no
it's all right zip stripe right yeah
yeah he made it through you one actually
you beat you showed that tree his boss
it was date already but anyway there's
another one there there's actually quite
a few but none of them at all no so
you'll be okay
I think that salami doesn't look like
tiny I don't I don't feel that she does
I feel that kochava looks more like
tündi looks more like Chinese daughter
Butler number is more unique-looking
lipid I think she's going to be bigger
than her mom I think she might already
be bigger than her mom
yeah oh yes climber's definitely
inherited a little personality from mum
definitely the strength and the courage
but physically no I don't think she
looks like a month but Catawba
definitely kochava carries that Corolla
female look really really clearly it's
obviously getting quite dark as you
might have noticed so we strolling along
very very close to camp mm-hmm Isana if
anything that you know I think he looks
like ting Ghana but we may yet be
surprised I think he's got the same sad
look they both look sad sometimes
certainly a poser
we're all just discussing half he he
thought there was an s ABC TV show
tonight and he's probably quite upset
that he is and he's been overshadowed so
to speak by the cricket is a tree there
Seb he he got it he made it blue all
right he going to stroll away from the
darkness and into the electrical lights
meantime grant has got his electrical
light out as well
yeah if I doubt asana is very big on his
cricket anymore he has definitely been
the star of our show up until now as you
see things have changed quite
dramatically since you all left me
husana as he dashed off of that termite
mound in the time that it took me to
turn around he managed to pull one of
his leopard tricks and I don't know
which direction he's gone now we're just
heading north along the road that was on
the western side of that block that he
was in just to see if he's crossed over
here although we are coming up towards
quarantine and a fairly open area so I'm
gonna do I think I'll do a loop around
the block yeah and let's see if if we
can pick up on anything now on my way
out I saw a couple duikers which I'm
sure he would take quite fondly - he did
not seem to be sneaking up on them so I
wonder what else caught his attention
cuz he did he did run off with quite a
bit of intent so
and if we can figure out what it was now
this is I think what he was waiting for
while he was sitting on top of that
termite mound while he was sitting on
top of that termite mound I think he
might have just been waiting for it to
get dark before he moved and ha ha
a classic German leopard move indeed
everybody
I think leopard move in general but
being in this area I'm sure you know the
humor lipids quite well and this is
pretty standard leopard behavior
I don't feel too bad that he might be on
his own at the moment and although we
try and not interfere with his his
hunting you know being a little bit
darker and in quieter what might help
him and I sometimes when lepers do get
to the point where they're tired of
being followed as accommodating as they
may be might sometimes just dash off nah
I'm not trying to get out of the fact
that that I wasn't quick enough in
following him but I think that might be
why we can't find him again and yeah
like I said I think he was waiting
pretty to get dark
alright I think while we try and catch
up with him
it sounds like Pat might have something
for you so let's head over to Pat to see
what he's up to
I am in infrared now which is why the
colors are a little bit different than
what you would be used to seeing at the
moment now I did go through and check a
couple of the hyena dents but
unfortunately no luck at the moment but
that's okay so the reason I went through
them even though I was going to be
looking for tyranny is because where the
tracks come out for the high in it then
it's kind of on the road where the
tracks are timely were found so I'll
just make my way through see if they are
out yet which they weren't and now I can
still around fatality for another 10
minutes or so and then I'll go back and
see if there is some activity at the den
so it killed two birds with one stone
hopefully we get the both of them will
actually know if I find Tandy I think
I'll definitely stick with her but the
fact that the tracks did say well the
person that came across the tracks was
Herbie I definitely trust that they are
worth following up because that man is a
very very experienced I was saying
before about how you do need years of
experience to really properly be able to
track something and he is a man who has
it that sort of experience this is
getting quite dark now as we are in
infrared I've got this spotlight to help
me but the road is looking quite clear
so if there are any tracks on the road I
think should still be able to pick up on
them with relative ease sometimes it can
get a little bit more tricky in darkness
coming down into a drainage line now so
I'll definitely slow down through that
one of the first things we were taught
out here is to always have a look better
look when you are down in a dry riverbed
2 4 4 leopards as it is quite dense and
cool and shaded and covered now
everyone's saying that they have missed
the hyenas over the last few days yeah
so I mean it is almost a daily thing
that we do go in and check on them but I
guess it hasn't been done it recently
and well I hope they do it come out a
little bit later on if we can't find
tandy because as well I miss the hyenas
it is such a good way to end the day
because obviously we tend to go look
there more in early morning Kate I have
never seen any of these drainages
actually it filled with water in my time
here at Juma but one when there is rains
in the summer it will be a channel down
through it but I'm just trying to think
it back in summer I think there was even
then I believe the mo RT was still quiet
dry it's more the pans and that that
we'll start to see it fill up that's
this time of year yeah it's I mean it's
generally always quite dry and this time
of year we're definitely not going to
expect to see that at all because well
we're just not gonna get rain this time
of year simple as that
although this morning it got
surprisingly overcast the sky was almost
completely grey at one point this
morning it did almost feel like it was
about to rain but it never actually came
ROI well that's actually a really good
question it does seem like this year the
fire alert is a little bit higher so the
sabi sands region in general is quite a
fire shaped habitat you know it is prone
to fires and whereas actually I was
talking to Steph the other day who's
saying the last four or five years there
hasn't been as much grass cover and
therefore not as high as a fuel load and
so the risk of fires hasn't been as
severe but even as we can see to my
right and my left at the moment there's
quite a lot of tall moribund grass which
is a bit of a fire hazard and apparently
this year it's a lot higher than
previous years so there is a bit more of
a risk which I mean it kind of is it
does seem like a terrible thing but
fires especially in Savannah ecosystems
can really shape the ecosystem and do a
lot of good despite the initial
destruction one of those things even
being the what I was just speaking about
with the fuel load obviously once a fire
goes through that is diminished so it
can help to keep it low there's also a
lot of in of fire prone areas especially
a lot of trees that have adapted so that
their seeds kind of release after a fire
in seed resistant pods or they have
other mechanisms to cope with a fire
sometimes they'll have growths under the
trees that can carnival morning sowing
grasses that will kind of regenerate
after a fire has come through so as long
as the whole plant itself hasn't been
diminished or destroyed then it can
regrow and it also allows a lot more
light and a lot more a lot less cover in
whatever layer it may be so if we're
speaking for example about the grass
layer well then it clears out all of
that space that is needed for light and
allows the new healthier shoots to come
through
so all comes back to succession really
so after a disturbance such as a fire
you will get what is called succession
so walks in I believe yes so there is
four fire breaks around this property so
one running kind of parallel to each
boundary
are you still going down this way
okay well I will continue to follow
these trucks around see whether I can
pick up on although I'm at the southern
boundary and they were heading south so
another good sign but anyway let's go
through Grant who is trying it to get
back on to house on his tail
thanks Pat yeah still trying to follow
indeed I haven't had any luck yet I did
see some impalas crossing into the block
that that whole sauna was in we've just
come down to check chela pan there's a
scrub here over here but nothing in the
form of a lipid this is if you if anyone
was watching last night this is the
corner around which we came and stumbled
upon calamba in fact that's exactly
where I saw her over there and there's
some eyes on the ground which might be
as something like a night jar or
something small but she was here last
night as well and I'm just gonna head
back towards a well Sanne came out of
the drainage line and Dawn
I don't know how far horse Anna's scent
would travel exactly um speaking of
sense I don't if anyone's ever actually
smart what lipid scent smells like it
actually smells like buttered popcorn
which is quite delightful although that
is what their urine smells like but and
if that sort of st. mark is fresh then
in terms of human ability we'd probably
smell it from a few meters away but
nothing much more than that when you've
got the senses of an Impala or something
along those lines they would probably
pick up on a lipid scent 20 30 40 meters
away maybe if the wind is is strong
enough and blowing in that direction so
it very much depends on the wind
I would imagine yeah I have not smelled
any popcorn smell yet the other son of
him so far um so some viewers are
wondering if the scent marking would
affect a leopards hunting ability now
they probably if they were actively
hunting as in stalking or trying to
follow up on something they wouldn't
really st. mark at the same time so they
would hunt and all their focus would be
on on the quarry which they would be
stalking in between stalking their prey
whatever we should check down there
let's go have a look down here again in
terms of stalking their prey in between
actual stalks they may start st. marking
and sure if if there was something sort
of downwind from wherever they st. mark
they would definitely pick up on that
easier then if the lipid wasn't st.
marking and that urine is is quite a
strong smell and one of my favorite
smells in the bush
all right Nancy I would say that it is
[Music]
popcorn not microwave popcorn but
popcorn in general so if I even if I go
to the movies or something when I'm in
the city in Johannesburg the first thing
that comes to my mind when I walk past
the movie houses is his leopard since
sorry leopard scent and and if someone's
cooking popcorn at home on the stove in
some oil that also triggers that memory
for me so yeah just general popcorn as
long as it's properly made but microwave
popcorn doesn't have the same smell to
me and it's actually not particularly
Leopards it might be slightly different
with other smaller cat and like Janet's
they also have a very sort of battery
popcorn smell to them which is quite
nice sometimes we living out of Janet's
living in our ruse and and you can smell
that when they're quite active
on that note I think I'll send you back
to Pat who I believe is sniffing and
looking around for a leopard himself
well whatever those tracks has crossed
into the southern boundary so just
making them my way back up now to the
hyena den and hopefully we have some
activity this afternoon
it would have been very cool to have
caught up with Tandy but we will leave
that for another time in a very animals
have been quite elusive at this
afternoon I've kind of been trying a lot
tonight but not really getting too far
with things but that's alright as I
always say you win some and you lose
some and I've had plenty of luck over
this last week I've actually been having
a lot more leopard sightings than I was
expecting
took a while to get going in my first
week or so here but then I have a really
lucky run a really hot streak with the
leopards and well it's been very good
very keeps you going and it also makes
these quieter drives such as this one
just you know that little bit more you
can accept it a little bit more and it's
still quite enjoyable just to drive
around and well see some of the other
interesting things other than leopards
like today the the the fish eagle and
the Egyptian goose emma is so just
saying that it also gives me the chance
to work on my spotlighting skills which
is very true it is something that can
get a little bit tedious at times is it
talking and flash lighting and driving
at the same time well there can always
go with a little bit of refinement I
haven't even had a pair of glowing eyes
yet usually by this time of night
there's at least a scrub hair about
now I need to keep my eyes peeled here
for the entrance to the hyena den
because sometimes if you don't pay
attention at nighttime it can pass very
quickly so I will be tending to look a
little bit more to this side of me
usually the cold is starting to set in
so I am going it who put on a jumper and
well Stu I jump up let's send you back
to grant who also seems to be working on
his spotlighting skills
Thank You patty ah but a practice with
the spotlight goes a long way although I
haven't found anything with it just yet
but I believe there's some impalas alarm
calling up towards the juma damn cam and
that was part of our next step in our
search for husana now it became a bit of
a guessing game as to which direction he
may have turned in and as we were trying
to think like a leopard earlier we've
been doing that again and we were
wondering if he carried on sort of
heading southwest and maybe doing a
little bit of hunting in that area or if
he had looped back and gone back towards
the the Jimmer damn camera we are Taylor
down so I think I've just dipped my
lights because I think there's a vehicle
stopped up in front here for a break I
want to interfere with that too much I
think we're just gonna nip past them
here and head straight back up to the
dam and see what might have upset those
impalas it's too hopeful outcomes either
Masana has head back to his favorite
haunt or maybe some of them Kahoot my
members have come back to the dam
it might even it might even be one of
the female lipids that have been moving
around this area in the last couple days
so it's just sneak posture you bring
everyone and see
if we have any luck at the dance
we're not far away fortunately so should
be there in a few seconds
the dam has been a hot spot on melting
part of activity today and last night
actually quite jealous of those who were
watching all the action go down
yesterday and so let's hope that it
attracts the same sort of attention as
it has been
just checking tracks along the road as
we go it usually helps to dip the light
down at a bit of a lower angle so that
the shadows are cost into the track so
we can see it but nothing fresh over
here
some eyes up ahead there but I think
those are more Impala I'm just judging
about how they're moving about and
they're usually not as bright as a
nocturnal creatures eyes that is because
of the adaption that nocturnal animals
have in order to see better at night
they have I forgot the name now have a
sort of a lens at the back of the eye
that reflects light back through their
retina which helps them see at night
which usually stands up quite nicely in
a spotlight
okay
last minute lipid I think it rolls off
the tongue quite nicely and that's
usually a pretty good way to end off and
afternoon all the way all right I don't
know I think like Pat was saying you
know you win some you lose some
lose some and I think this afternoon the
amount of quality real top-quality time
that we spent with
hasana may have been all of our luck
used up for today at least hopefully but
let's just quickly pop around the corner
here you can see up ahead
all right I think let's head back over
to Pat to see how he's doing for the end
of the show and I'm gonna go and have
one final look at the damp if we do find
anything have to check up with us later
so let's pop over to Pat to see what
he's got still making my way up to the
high in attend the entrance that we
usually use for some reason or another
has been blocked off and so I've got to
make my way around a bit so I'm not
exactly sure why but obviously there is
some reason and I want to respect that
and so we will come around the other way
and pray pray pray pray that we do have
some hyenas coming out to greet us
so just a reminder to everyone that
there isn't an S a b c show tonight
because of the cricket and so that is
why we are treated to a three-hour drive
rather than our usual two on sundays but
we will be back next week and i'm sure
it's going to be a very exciting episode
i know we were all very keen for tonight
and everyone's wondering whether a hyena
cub a pesky hyena car that used biggest
sticks to block the dead
no these definitely looks like they were
moved by humans i think they were a bit
too large for a hyena to handle
especially a little cub although they do
love to play around with their sticks oh
so we are in a bit of a last minute us
surprise here hopefully we can get some
hyenas not far from the den if we do get
to see them it won't be for very long
but better some hyenas at there none
resting at Thomas
so it seems like there are some gremlins
and if there is any problems with my
audio I do apologize it's not all you
are worried about right now it's the
visuals and Laurie hyenas so we have an
empty den so we'll have to be closing
the show with an empty den I'd apologize
but I hope you did enjoy tonight's drive
at least we did to catch up with hasana
and well I think that little bird so I
think earlier was quite interesting as
well but as for now it's time to say
goodbye thank you all so much for
joining if you would like to join us
again at please Dury in the morning for
how I end drive as for now goodbye and
good night
[Music]